a experiência de vida
um profissional
como iniciei minha carreira como a gente
enfrenta o nosso dia a dia
então minha carreira não foi fácil
difícil porque na hora que você começa
uma profissão eo país numa época que é
cozinheiro era considerado uma produção
subiu emprego mais difícil ainda porque
a profissão não era valorizada um belo
horizonte teve a sorte de receber em
belo horizonte
um professor um francês tinha vindo da
frança
o chef copacabana palace chefe do
shopping no áudio do shopping e abril em
belo horizonte a primeira escola de
hotelaria muita gente não sabe
belo horizonte teve a primeira escola de
formação de mão de obra para cozinheiros
e profissionais nessa área não ingressei
muito novo com dizeres em 14 anos de
idade num e queria ser garçom detestado
a cozinha
nunca quis ser cozinheiro 1 mas depois
de um ano estudando todas as matérias
descobri que não podia ser garçom um
momento que o público num a seleção
os cozinheiros um lado para o outro um
pessoa de cor não podia ser garçom
naquela época eu fui para a cozinha
contrariado que sair não quis com queria
continuar na mão não vai continuar
morava no bairro 1º de maio o situação
difícil num país com minha mãe meu pai
com sete anos de idade que usava de
realmente ganhar uma profissão e tinha
de buscar ali uma profissão digna para
mim
seis meses depois eu falei assim aqui
que eu vou me virar
o curso é longo de três anos
então comecei a gostar da profissão e o
que muitas vezes as pessoas de hoje não
fazem
enxergar uma pessoa como mestre mestre
você adora ama e quer ser igual à que
era francês então dediquei a ser ele no
futuro
e trabalhei a trabalhar em cima disso
com 17 anos 16 anos de idade estava
dando aula em 32 anos na escola com 19
anos de idade já era chefe dos melhores
o advogado horizonte num ganhava bem a
dez salários mínimos
com 19 anos de idade em uma casa minha
casa minha mãe pulso de comprar primeira
geladeira televisão e assim organizar a
minha vida mas tinha uma coisa que
muitas vezes as pessoas esquecem hoje
que é muito importante preparar melhor
para enfrentar profissão no futuro
eu olhei pra ser assim só tinha quarto
no grupo 1
a cena era o patrão pra você pra que
isto dá pra que é um belo de um
cozinheiro você detona 22 anos naquela
época não não estou saindo dele ficar um
ano e preparar um burro fazer supletivo
comecei a estudar francês um poder
supletivo fez com os pés no chão ea
técnica e fui substituir aquele francês
o paulo carneiro
mas com um detalhe sabe quando um você
nenhum professor na sua frente mas se
não pode aproximar franceses um chefe
muitas vezes dependendo do chefe não são
muito duros e ele era do todo mundo
afastava dele diz o contrário
mas nessa minha decisão de me preparar
quando eu fui o paulo carneiro num mesmo
antes de fato um grande amigo
toda semana na casa dele é assim eu
cresci muito mais fácil
ganhei mais segurança ainda tem um outro
detalhe quando você pega sua profissão
ainda falta muita coisa na profissão há
continuava sendo um subemprego um
cozinheiro não pôde no salão a um quem
pôde no salão era sua meta
vamos quebrar esta barreira invertida
espaço onde trabalhava
eu era a principal pessoa do restaurante
essa situação mudou
todos que vieram trabalhar comigo passou
a enxergar produção de uma forma
diferenciada
quem eu dava aula e preparava preparava
para ser um profissional de cozinha
altura não ser aquele profissional que
fica na retaguarda ano aguardando a
ordem de 1 metro de um gerente da casa
ou de um dono
mas na frente que é outro objetivo
pensar em europa nunca era muito longe
do outro lado do oceano como chegar lá
parecia uma bolsa de estudo
a bolsa de estudo maravilhosa uma vaga
onde parece a bolsa de estudo
não era difícil mas bom currículo bom
bom profissional e conhecimento da
língua francesa ter 2º grau completo já
tinha a bolsa família
o brasil inteiro queria a bolsa na suíça
cheguei incrível que pareça na suíça
quando cheguei
cheguei com um profissional de ponta não
como profissional comum
isso surpreendeu os grandes professores
não só isso
quando você chega como do brasil que a
maioria das vezes perguntava enquanto
que nos comove no brasil senão cipó cipó
das onze pode medir-se pode 11 horas tem
bicho na cidade tem sim tem bicho na
porta da casa passa cobra jacaré e até
de fanti tirava um sarro estão
enfrentando umas feras feras não porque
eu não sabia trabalhar veras porque eu
sabia trabalhar
então como eu tinha respondido à
capacidade de substituir substituí-los
pesado
eu trabalhava o dobro
era muito mais fácil pegar uma folga eu
substituí lo e assim foi durante quase
dois anos e para mim foi muito bom
porque chamar a atenção era um dedo da
ponta do nariz dia pior de eu vou contar
para vocês eu sai da mesa de café tinha
dois dedos um frio de lá
lá fora está fazendo 10 graus e la salle
exigentes café da forma que eu joguei o
café fora
o ligue o pessoal está atrás de mim e
vem dando abrigo desta manhã foi
encostando aparelho é é esse canto fora
você nunca foi à guerra mas que nunca
foi à guerra
rico já fui à dela não nunca fui à
guerra
por isso nunca passou fome e me encostou
no canto da parede e me xingou porque os
dois dentro café fora
aí você vê o quanto que estas pessoas
valorizam um alimento e nós aqui neste
país
não valorizamos muitas vezes aquilo que
é nosso e nada
nossos filhos
nós não ensinamos nossos filhos a
valorizar os nossos produtos
a nossa cultura muitas vezes não
ensinamos 1 e cozinha é base de uma
família é a base na mesa que criamos que
discutimos os melhores momentos com os
filhos
hoje muitas vezes muitas famílias não
existe isso
mas graças a deus está voltando a
quantidade de alunos que eu tenho que
amo fazer com cozinha hoje para poder
fazer uma boa comida para a família
reunir todos em volta da mesa e poder
voltar ser aquela família do passado
isso é muito bom e continuando a minha
história
essa minha volta para o brasil foi uma
coisa melhor do mundo quando eu voltei
da suíça pra cá mas quando cheguei que
eu queria voltar
eu estava acelerado demais
eu era uma tabela a ferrari e todo mundo
aqui andando assim e eu atropelando eu
não aguentava aquilo eu eu não podia
quando eu trabalhava lá eu não podia
perder o luxo de andar quatro metros
pegar um produto voltar e depois ter de
voltar lá para pegar outro que trazer
tudo ao mesmo tempo não dava conta de
preparar tudo durante o dia não podia
geladeira duas vezes pedi poder trazer
tudo colocar aqui eu tivesse duas vezes
atrapalhava tutinha ser cronometrado
então hoje eu sou um empresário luto
como empresário não é fácil
cheguei de 200 funcionários hoje eu
tenho um pouco mais de 100
aproveitei sempre os momentos de crise a
crescer
nunca mandei ele ir embora na crise é
isso que eu acho que a gente tem de
acreditar
a formação com nós preparamos e nos
preparamos para ser um profissional
competente não fazer o que alguns fazem
eu posso conversar com você pode pessoa
tem 30 anos
o tem 40 ontem 28 em dúvida na profissão
dele o que está fazendo está querendo
desistir
com 30 anos um iniciar uma nova
profissão
as pessoas não têm tempo hoje aprender
com e com o carinho a profissão quando
tem 17 18 19 20 anos ele vai começar a
querer aprender lá um depois dos 20 25 e
que é impressa de ganhar dinheiro
a profissão de cozinha a profissão e
demora demora demora para se tornar um
certo e fizemos uma coisa tudo na toda
profissão é uma pirâmide
aqui estão os líderes é que tem uma base
que vão crescendo juntos nós invertemos
essa base
aqui tem um monte de gente
miranda chefe e aqui tem uma base
pequena porque o único lugar que eu já
vi no mundo e uma pessoa para fazer
curso de cozinha começa fazendo curso em
uma faculdade em vez de começar uma
escola de aprendizado com seus 16 anos
de idade ou 15 anos de idade para se
tornar um profissional para se tornar
uma pessoa competente onde estiver com
22 23 24 25 anos de idade é o inverso
então começa pela faculdades após alunos
em belo horizonte hoje 2 mais de dois
mil alunos
sabe quantos vão trabalhar no mercado
não sei
o mínimo então eu vim aqui pra dar um
recado de profissionalismo não importa
qual profissão
quem determina o que eu quero ser sou eu
não é o sistema o sistema aí
agora eu determino que eu quero ser eu
quero ser um belo de um líder com
competência nem que demora em dois ou
três anos na escola 14 anos cinco anos
o médico demora quanto tempo um e
cozinha muito mais na europa uma cozinha
agora trabalhando e vai continuar
fazendo isso mais um longo tempo um
eu até hoje não sei nada estou
aprendendo
estou buscando conhecimento a cada dia
lennon
as pessoas aprendem
para de ler hora de pesquisar ea vida
foi feita para pesquisar a vida inteira
não é para aprender uma profissão
estagnar o estudo pertence à nossa vida
quem tem uma profissão quem quer ser bom
na profissão tem de estudar e pesquisar
todos os dias porque tem hoje
isso aqui nunca a nossa jaqueta maioria
das pessoas não dão valor quando eu
visto essa jaqueta é uma transformação
obrigado
[Aplausos]